quand j'étais petit le monde grouillait
de dragon rares sont ceux qui savent où
ils sont allés notre histoire a changé
le monde à jamais on a réussi un monde
idéal où vivent en harmonie dragon
speaking ton monde idéal on lit des
halles amwaj à moi j'en compris plus jj
yannick moment où tu vas
au mieux il est donc famille c'est un
dragon femelle nous sommes désolés et
vient de se volatiliser
un monde caché de dragon
allez vous vous présentez comme moi une
petite copine j'ai chassé tous les furie
nocturne excepté le tien livres le mois
jamais je ne livrerai dans ce cas je
détruirai tout ce que tu tiens
on est plus en sécurité ici on doit tous
se cacher disparaître
nous devons nous battre pour leur
liberté allez vous
santon dragon tu n'es rien
montrent leur ce que tu as dans le
ventre
[Musique]
sauf le
toi et moi mon grand pour toujours
[Musique]